juni nicht von mir ich gehe zu den ich
fand das gut besetzte apfel
jetzt essen sogar giftig wenn die nicht
gewartet ähnlich hatte ich hab ne giftig
ritter warte den arena gucken was sie
macht euch was sie zu essen mehr da ist
ging es manche gewinnt ist keine normale
kartoffeln draußen einzig richtige das
ganze gibt es die ganze ein bisschen
stirbt ja weg ich habe den er dann
seinen loch geworfen
es ist nicht lustig ihn zu lang
das ist nicht lustig okay vielleicht so
viel arbeit eigentlich schon gewonnen
was neues thema neues thema schon wieder
wir sind jetzt gerade werden genau vier
folgen durch das schaffe ich mein haus
oder das gut was nehmen wir denn dies
ist nach brauchen die wasser die
kartoffeln sowie ok und moderne bauten
vergrößern
was muss man genau sein aber möhren
musst du nicht platten nicht ganz so als
last und hören kannst du jetzt schweine
pan und kartoffeln liebling der ganz was
meine freunde der freunde was meine
freunde ist eure meinung zu sozialen
netzwerken kommentar oder kann wieder
eine komplette stunde oder quatschen
eine folge lang
dann legt man los ich zu euch den
vortritt ließ
das den er den vortritt ich habe schon
die frage wo gelesen vielleicht doch
ausgerechnet für den heute den habt ihr
alle der name ist von cyber fans mlp der
die frage stellt ob ist und ich geb dir
noch ein kleines im kommentar dazu dass
auch mit beantworten darfst du aber gibt
sie aber die leute der schuh 24/7 mit
ihren handys jahr zwischen einfach in
der schule nicht mehr unterbieten
das sollte band wurden ich meine wer ist
das mittlerweile nicht
ich habe also nicht mehr in der schule
bist weil du noch nicht wieder in der
schule bist ja nur soziale netzwerke ein
ein neuartiges phänomen der letzten des
letzten jahrzehnts artig erst
verwirklicht soziale netzwerk ist ja
eigentlich ein grund auch schon mal
falsch weil es heißt ja social networks
aber das ist nicht sozial netzwerke
sondern socialize sich sozial sondern
gesellschaftlich zws wird diesen
zusammenhang genutzt haben ist schon mal
immer alles wenn die männer sagen diese
sozialen netzwerke sind gar nicht sozial
die müssen noch nicht sozial sein denn
es sind einfach soziale netzwerke und
genau das sind sie ja auch es ist dieses
gesellschaftlichen wir sind ja keine
soziale netzwerke sind sind jetzt
soziale netzwerke die fluggesellschaften
jetzt weg wo man sicherheit mit ja mit
dem personenkreis eigentlich verbindet
den man ja selbst auch angehört
das eigentliche sinn und darüber
kommuniziert und das ist eine sehr
sinnvolle sache sowieso schon mal wenn
man dadurch einnehmen
das ist eine sehr sinnvolle sache und ob
man sich jetzt darüber organisiert und
kommuniziert oder über telefon macht
jetzt auch nicht den großen unterschied
zu schalten wir das einmal nicht die
zeit damit verschwendet verschwenden
kann aber das ist jetzt endlich das
problem der sozialen netzwerke sondern
wenn
man sich selbst davon nicht losreißen
kann oder es ist nicht das problem
mit seiner last auf alle medien zu holen
also erstmal dazu dass er ganz viele
leute meinen facebook ja voll schlecht
davon wieder voll schnell süchtig also
ich sags mal so man kann von allem
wichtig werden egal was es ist als
kochen sei es locken selbst zb alkohol
süchtig oder irgendwie sowas man kann
mittlerweile von allen sichtlich hätten
deswegen finde ich das argument an sich
total holte nach unsinn außerdem nicht
süchtig von facebook sondern man wird da
von süchtigen anderen in kontakt steht
einfach sozusagen im mittelpunkt zu
stehen oder andere zu sein dass jemand
like genau wieso er jedenfalls
man wird doch kochen süchtig und strauss
ja und er ja genau den am 1 im jahr ob
wir jetzt alles per telefon plant oder
über facebook ist eigentlich egal und
zwar finde ich dass facebook doch sehr
sehr viele vorteile gegenüber telefon
sms sonstigen was hat und zweitens
erstens ich sags mal so kostenlos also
internet kost natürlich auch was vertrag
oder so kommt doch im moment ist aber es
ist so erstmal kostenlos man kann der
soll anderen sein wie man will wenn
flatrate hat keine ahnung und die zweite
sache ist man kann darüber viel besser
irgendwelche dingens planen so
ereignisse
man ist damit immer auf dem neuesten
stand wann hat wer geburtstag und so
weiter oder zum beispiel was
mittlerweile jede schule eigentlich hat
es dass man in jeder stufe sonne gruppe
hat wo dann über die hausaufgaben rein
gepostet werden und das ist eigentlich
immer ganz hilfreich
deswegen finde ich facebook an sich im
alltag beim ihr seid mal ohne facebook
würde bei mir nicht mehr funktionieren
nicht weil ich einfach nur den ganzen
tag da drin wenn sondern einfach weil
ich abends zum beispiel nicht mehr weiß
höhe was heute schon funktionieren das
würde nur nicht mehr vieles würde nicht
mehr funktionieren was man im moment
macht aber erste alter natürlich ganz
normal
trotzdem würde er natürlich
funktionieren ich meine server liefert
diese dinge nicht mehr sein
es wäre nicht so einfach
und vor allem ist es schön dass man auch
immer erreichbar wie gesagt hast zum
beispiel hat der vorteil am abend wenn
man ganztagsschule arbeitende schule ist
danach zu tun
und jemand möchte trotzdem mit dir in
kontakt beim ich meine das schreibt ihr
eine nachricht und die empfängst du dann
halt wenn du dann zu hause bist und muss
nicht genau dann zeit haben wenn er
anruft zum beispiel läuft natürlich auch
besser flexibel mit ja und was ich auch
ganz gut finde ich es gibt ja sehr viele
verschiedene zwecke mittlerweile und das
finde ich auch wieder ganz geil dass man
sich da so eins aussuchen kann ich mein
facebook gesetzter zu der die post des
fotos bilder du kannst veranstaltungen
über das mit dem aussuchen machen ist
eigentlich
du kannst ja auch noch twitter machen wo
zum beispiel einfach nur die ganzen
leute gerade posten was sie gerade
machen
dann gibt es wieder was gibt's da sonst
noch es gibt noch so was wie instagram
wo wirklich nur fotos sind aber da kann
man mittlerweile auch alles kommentieren
und so es gibt da wirklich sondern so
eine große bandbreite und aber facebook
ist echt zum mittlerweile dass das hat
wirklich jeder siebte jeder achte auf
der welt für 10 euro zurück da ist das
was wir uns eben das ist es gar nicht
gegeben dass man sich aussuchen kann man
es ja jeder kann sich sein netzwerk
aussuchen aber eigentlich ist das ja gar
nicht geben weil man also schülervz kann
es eigentlich nicht mehr benutzen weil
da einfach nicht mehr genug leute sind
eigentlich facebook benutzt du kannst
jetzt nicht hier sagen ja gut ich
benutze jetzt facebook-konkurrent muss
man jetzt eher mal sich anschauen und
nicht twitter bald wird er ein schon
etwas anders als als facebook sondern
zum beispiel myspace war bei myspace ja
auch ein bisschen anders ist aber was
früher gab friends da könnt ihr alle gar
nicht mehr
lokalisten aber ich meine schauen ich
meine auch wenn ich sage kennt ihr alle
nicht mehr manche soll nicht alles
sondern ich mein so ein großteil kennt
es nicht mehr also führt letztlich
diskriminiert wenn das kind oder das
gerne alles tag meinte wer kennt wen
oder so was alles ja in deutschland
boomt das aber auch sonst nirgendwo
würden wieder prozentpunkt sonst auch
neben zwei deutschland ist er aber nicht
mehr ich ins studio gehen wir halt mal
studivz als beispiel das ist total am
absterben
ich weiß nicht ob es überhaupt noch
geführt wird aber das verliert krass so
krass viele nutzer dazu facebook richtig
und man kann sich eben nicht aussuchen
also wenn man wenn man unzufrieden ist
zum beispiel mit den datenschutz problem
von facebook da kann man nicht sagen
gute - sich als studivz weil es ist
ziemlich deutlich besser geregelt der
nähe das ist ja auch so länder leute
sagen ja ich hab allgemeine problem
damit meine dafür auszugeben sind die
oft und gar keinem netzwerk fast weil du
dass es mittlerweile über das denken wo
du drauf klickt damit sie dafür für dich
zum beispiel anzeigen schalten
das heißt er ich würde nicht sagen dass
seiner sagte facebooks wir dazu unsere
user gegenüber zu studivz oder so wenn
ein studivz ist eben was datenschutz
angeht deutlich deutlich besser weil die
auch mit den deutschen datenschützern
zusammenarbeit trotzdem wird er dann das
ist eigentlich als einzige argument zu
zu denen zu gehen muss man kann eben
nicht zu denen gehen weil das sind deine
freunde nicht an denn sie alle zu wenn
er zu einem geht wenn er zu facebook zum
beispiel nicht will dann will ja
eigentlich auch zu keinem anderen weil
studivz wenn man möchte dass und das
finde ich nicht gut datenschutz mäßig
gut bei schülervz ist es besser gelöst
da kann ich hier aber einfach nur ein
billiger abklatsch von facebook aber die
zentrale die datenschutz problematik ist
auf jeden fall besser gelöst
auch wenn ich ansonsten natürlich
nachgemacht ist das stimmt natürlich zu
ich würde eher sagen dass studivz ein
abklatsch von schülervz oder anders
die gehören alle zusammen die stimmung
ist hier an der tagesordnung
habt ihr noch bis zum glas finde ich
dass ich vielleicht heute mit zwölf
minuten mein thema gequatscht ich gar
nicht ich muss mir ja ich hätte ein
bisschen oder das alles was mit holz aus
dem wald holen das maskieren werde
deswegen können eigentlich langsam bis
in mein bett eigentlich hin ist auch
kaputt gehen bei der städtisches projekt
imst den ich sachen von mir ich gehe zu
den ich fand es gut dass neben prof
geben wir echt mal schlafen nicht
marktmacht nicht so gerne ohne lena wird
beim basketball solchen stoffen jedem
bau dir doch im bett solo kann ohne
frage ihr habt ja mega viel was haben
wir das der negativ wolle gaddafi wolle
kam meinst du kannst mir ungefähr vier
sechs oder sogar von gekämpft das ist
naturschutzgebiet
ich fand immer wieder neu ab die ich
brauche das dunkle fichten und ich bin
meinen boden setzt genau da aber dann
wieder so ein setzling hin weil das soll
bald die haben wir extra dafür
angelegten kleinen und ich würde auch
sagen wenn winter ist dann könnt ihr das
schön so schnell hinsetzen weil ich
meine wenn wir die ganzen folgen jetzt
aufgenommen haben dann wird bestimmt
schon wenn sie die letzte folge von
dieser aufnahme session sehen bestimmt
schon mitte november ist euch eigentlich
aufgefallen dass ich die letztes mal
auch nachgepflanzt habe genauso ich es
gar nicht wahr dass ich alle abgabe und
alle nachgepflanzt hat aber das ganz gut
gift also ich weiß noch dass park die
einfach abgebaut hat und da bin ich so
was schon ausgerastet und danach ist
unser ding ist er gegangen
unterteilt weil spark da irgendwie
prepaid park war allgemein komisch als
packard
zwar konnte gar nicht reden weil wir uns
in den halbfinalen wir haben es einfach
über ein thema diskutiert und spark hat
konnte ihn nicht mitreden konnte schon
aber ziemlich nah und naja und dann sind
wir sind auch halt wir sind beide mit
hirn rumgelaufen wo die ganze zeit
getötet und wie ihre ganze haus
beschäftigt oder ich dann legen den
rathaus hat die sonne sehr suboptimal
darf ich haben wolle und rote blumen
also du kannst du dir weil du kannst du
dir wolle sowohl selber ganz einfach vom
oder ideen ich bin dafür dass wir
schlafen gehen wochenbett kannst du für
dich kannst du doch wollen wollen nehmen
oder wenn du bei mir bis dann gebe ich
dir wolle
und ja ich bin bei dir und ich auch glas
wollte noch geben
rechtsträger waren bett nein das war
voller back das ist aber mein bett hier
ich habe wolle für dich kräfte lenker
des turniers nimm dir da drei holte ich
will ich neben dem schlafen
doch haye ist jedoch nicht auf das bald
mal ja aber kämpfen kann ihn nicht
schlafen leg dich hin
also ich glaube alle schlafen warum ist
jetzt endlich ein bisschen denn du heißt
es danke und du so bestehen ist business
days mehr oder sie jaycee der sänger ist
gut so denn sie hat mich ein bisschen
genervt so ich war zwei eisen damit
nicht nur gustav gans nur 117 alter das
wird aber noch eine große familie werden
soll ich noch mehr dings absichtlich
pflanzen oder walter das werde ich alles
noch zu bauen müssen das wird richtig
groß viel arbeit egal was du tun für die
nächsten folgen
heute soll ich überall berichtet setzen
dass das so eine winterlandschaft weil
ich freue mich ganz gut so dass es nicht
zu das sollte auch kein fetter mäßiger
bald seines mal gar nicht mehr
durchkommt durch kommt man von ab
hier setzt man sich schon und erstmal an
alle die jetzt bei mir zu gucken und
sagen ey du kannst doch einfach eine
schicht darüber fahren will ich aber
nicht weil ich nicht will dass danach
her dann ganz viele monster drin sporn
und sohn dann sagen wir welche
elefantenpark an den decken
ja aber ich will venture als zu bauen
weil man kann ja auch nicht einfach ein
haus bauen indem man da einfach nur
nicht in eine 15 meter erde darüber
setzt und dann einfach das haus drauf
bauen sollte schon ein bisschen doch das
geht aber klar dass wieder die subtile
meinung zum voraus kommt vorschein
das waren der meinung subtil
ich finde die ganzen die ganzen 19 c
eigentlich total geil ich finde
eigentlich gut manche beschweren sich am
einkauf wird jetzt viel realistischer
als freund ich mein fall
ich meine der standard minecraft style
dass man sich seine kasse den leiter sei